遠い昔宇宙飛行士に憧れて
本気で宇宙を目指した時期があったが
思いの外に虫歯が多すぎて
宇宙へ行くのを諦めたことがある
はじめしゃちょーです。
皆さん
今回は本当にヤバイですよ
なんとですね
宇宙飛行士の方から僕宛にメッセージが届いております
というわけで今回実際そのムービーがあるので
ちょっと皆さんで見ましょう
もう今本当に初見ですからね
いきますよ
（大西卓哉）はじめしゃちょーこんにちは！
JAXA宇宙飛行士の大西卓哉です！
私は今地上から約400km上空を飛行している
国際宇宙ステーションISSに滞在中です。
JAXAが国際宇宙ステーションISSの日本実験棟
「きぼう」で行っている最先端の宇宙実験を
もっとたくさんの人に分かりやすくお伝えするために
はじめしゃちょーの力を貸してもらえませんか？
はじめしゃちょーのクリエイターとしての手腕を活かして
ぜひ「きぼう」の宇宙実験が
地上の生活にどう役に立っているのかを
分かりやすく楽しく伝えていただければと思います
今回はじめしゃちょーをきぼうサイエンス360プロジェクトのチーフエクスペリメントオフィサー(CEO)に任命しますので
ぜひ一度筑波宇宙センターに足を運んで私達が行っている宇宙実験を実際に見て感じてください
きっと面白いと思いますよ
それではよろしくお願いします
うわぁなんか、すごいなぁ
宇宙飛行士の方から
個別にメッセージを頂けるとは何たる幸せ
まぁ今、大西さんがおっしゃっていた通り
宇宙のそのねなんかやってる事ってすごい難しくて
分かりづらい事が多い
で僕も実際そんな分かってないとこが有りまして
わたくしが今回おーでぃこしゅｄｓｌｓに託された依頼は
直接わたくしがJAXA筑波宇宙センターまで行って
実際に今宇宙でどのような研究とか実験とかがされているかっていうのをね
まぁ僕と一緒に皆さんで
こう学べていけたらいいなと思っております。
宇宙センターに行くだけでちょっとビビっちゃうんですけど。
いよいよこの私もJAXAの本拠地に行く時が来たか
はっはっはっはっは
宇宙は近いぞ～
というわけで今からJAXA筑波宇宙センターへ
行ってきます！
うわぁ～大西さ～ん
はい。というわけでこちら筑波の宇宙センターまで来ました
ご覧の通り入り口にはですね
ロケットの見本が置いてあります
なんかでも結構思ったより小さいですよね
あっでもでけぇわよく見たら
展示館「スペースドーム」でございます
うわすっげー
放送衛星らしいですよ
これないと皆さんテレビ見れなかったわけですからね
ヒロキさんありがとうは？
はいよかったですね（笑）
あ、これなか入れそうじゃないですか
うわぁすごいすごい
メカメカしい
宇宙飛行士さんはこういうのを
全部こういじってやっているわけですから
はい、というわけでこちらからが管制室になります
こんにちは
私「きぼう」日本実験棟のフライトディレクターを担当している
井田恭太郎です。
よろしくお願いします
今日のミッション服ぜひこれを着て
うわすごい
うわすごいもう足元まで
早速着ちゃってもよろしいですか？
はいぜひぜひ
はじめしゃちょー宇宙って
どの位の高さからかご存知ですか？
もう物凄い高い所って言う想像があるんですけど
一般的には100kmくらい
へ～
100kmを一般的に宇宙って定義しています
一旦宇宙空間に出てしまえば
あの～無重力の世界が待っています
液体の対流が起きにくいとか
沈殿が起きにくいとか
そういう環境で実験すること
その目的で作られたのが国際宇宙ステーション
国際宇宙ステーションを運用しているのは15ヶ国
これがあれですね「きぼう」の
上に付いているものが船内保管室
下に付いている長いのが船内実験室です
外の環境でも実験が色々出来ます
ロボットアームを使って
中から外にいろんな機器を出し入れして
実験ができるんですね
国際宇宙ステーションの中でも
あの一連の作業ができるっていうのは唯一の環境です
これをどう管制しているのか管制室を説明したいと思います
なるほどよろしくお願いします
うわ～
うわなんか映画で観たことある
これってもう今本当に本当の
（はじめ）うわぁすげ～
実は今ロボットアーム運用って殆どの事を地上からコマンドで出来るんですよ
はははその通りですね（笑）
（はじめ）いや～あれはテンション↑↑がりますね
小型衛星放出機構を説明する渡辺さんです
（はじめ）はい
（はじめ）あっよろしくお願いします。結構距離がまだありますね！
ここからはですね一般の方でも公開されていないみたいなので
（はじめ）まだホントの
ここはホント秘密です
（はじめ）ホントのトップシークレットですよね？
ほんとヤバイですよここからは
うおぉぉぉクリーンルームです
（はじめ）うわぁ
中広いですね
皆さんここが普通の人は入れないトップシークレットクリーンルームでございます
天井高い
スプリングが中に入っていてですね
これがこうパーンと飛んでいく
実物大の大きさはこのくらい
小型衛星自体はどんな事に使われたりしているんですか？
えっとですね。地球の写真を撮ったりとかですね
あとは表面にLEDとかを点灯して地球と通信しようとしたりですね
流星を紫外線で観測したりですね
もう１つあるんですね
「きぼう」の船外プラットフォーム
こういう手すり、取っ手がですね何ヶ所かありまして
ここを使って実験できないかなって考えたのが発想の始まりですね
ミッションとしては外側に取り付けてただ単に一年間晒して
割りとメディアに出ているのは「たんぽぽ」っていうミッションでして
山岸先生という方がいらっしゃいますけど
エアロゲルというものを使って
宇宙空間から飛んできたのか地球で生まれたのか
という話がどちらかというのがまだ
（はじめ）分かってない
（渡辺）分かってない
（はじめ）へぇ
これは宇宙ステーションから地球に近い軌道なので
今調べている一番のポイントは地球から有機物が宇宙に出ていけるかどうか
というのを調べている
（はじめ）ズバリ質問してもよろしいですか
（渡辺）はい
それは思いますね（笑）
（はじめ）あ思いますか（笑）
ええ
（はじめ）ここもあれですか？もうあれな場所ですか？
秘密ですよ。簡単には入れない
（石川）ここは浮かせる研究をやっている所です
（はじめ）浮かせる
あっあっこれですか？
はい
舞空術ですね
すいませんすいませんすいませんでした
あっ
静電気を使って浮かせる方法をこの研究室でやっているんですよ
何をやりたいかというとレーザーをがんがん当ててこいつを溶かしたい
（はじめ）浮かせながら？
金属系のものを溶かすと酸素があると酸素と反応して錆びちゃうので
この中真空になっています
４，６，８
うおっ
おぉ～
あぁ～なんか光が
えぇーていうことはもう溶けてますね
なんかもうとてつもない世界ですね
この装置だとなんでも溶かせるんですか？
浮けばね
プラスがいっぱい付いていないと力が働かないので落ちちゃうんですよ
（はじめ）金属類
金属は楽なんですけど
セトモノ系はなかなか難しくて宇宙でやっています
筑波宇宙センターの食堂ということで
やっぱ基本食は宇宙食なんですか？
もうホント一般的な
あっ基本的な？
はい
なるほどなるほど
JAXAのコップですよ
JAXAのほうじ茶とJAXAの煎茶ですよ
いただきます！
うん
宇宙食！？
本物宇宙食ですよね？
はい
ちょっと開けてみましょう
これ大西さんも食べているということですが
おぉ～
うまい
いや普通にバリバリ美味しいですよ
ごちそうさまでした
めちゃくちゃ美味しかったです
カツカレーぜひ皆さんも宇宙センターに来た時は食べてみてください
次はタンパク質結晶生成実験に関する説明を木平さんからしていただきます
（木平）はじめしゃちょーのために専用の実験室を用意致しました
（はじめ）すごい
「きぼう」の中でですねタンパク質を使った実験をしているんですけれども
私達の身体の中にですね10万種類以上のタンパク質があります
それぞれ働きも違うんですけれども
構造も違うんですね
形ですね
実はタンパク質ってすごく小さいので
顕微鏡で拡大してもこの形は見えません
そのために何をするかというと
結晶化
この結晶を使うことでこのタンパク質の構造というのが詳細に明らかにできます
なので具体的に私達が宇宙で何をしているかというと
このタンパク質の結晶を「きぼう」の中で作るということをしているということになります
（はじめ）なるほどなるほど
世の中にある病気に対する薬というのは
ある薬はこのタンパク質に結合するというように
それぞれ相手がいてきちんと結合することで薬になっているわけですね
これにしかくっつかないというものを考えるときに
やっぱりタンパク質の構造というのは非常に大事で
何も分からないところで闇雲にこれが効くかなあれが効くかなとやっているよりも
ここがこういう形をしているから
ここにこういう薬をつけてあげれば
がっちりはまって
効くんじゃないかというのが分かりやすくなると
地上でどれだけ頑張っても
なかなかもうこれ以上は良い結晶になりませんと
そこで出番になるのが宇宙
とりわけ微小重力状態という特殊な環境を提供できる
え～日本実験棟の「きぼう」の中
ということになります
物質がゆっくりゆっくり動いたほうが
実は結晶というのは綺麗に大きくなるというのが
知られています
その特徴を活かして宇宙でバチッとした
（はじめ）はっきりわかると
はっきり分かる写真が撮れる
ということで今日はですね
その結晶化を実際にやってもらおうと思います
（はじめ）おお
人工血液と言って輸血の代わりになるものを作る
研究をお手伝いさせて頂いているんですね
人工血液のもとになるタンパク質を使って
実際に結晶化してみたいと思います
あっこれを結晶化するんですね？
はい
じゃあ先ずガラスキャピラリーを取ってください
（はじめ）はい取りました
取りました？
はい
じゃあここにさして、3/4くらい液を
そしたらこのさした側と反対の上側ですね
上側をこの粘土で封をしてください
出来ましたね！
そしたら粘土が付いていない側にこれをさしてください
（はじめ）ゲルチューブですね
はい
難しい
（はじめ）これはさせてますか
あ～十分ですね！
よっしー
はい
これでじゃあこれじめしゃちょーの
（はじめ）ありがとうございます
はじめての結晶化ということで
我々の仕事は宇宙に単純にタンパク質を持っていくだけではなくて
この良い結晶が出る溶液の条件を決定するというのも仕事です
2つの濃度の違いのものがこのガラス管の中で発生するわけですね
そうするとその都合のいいどこかで条件があったところで結晶がポコっと出ると
この中でタンパク質の実験を行っています
（はじめ）この中に一般の人は入れない
入れません
シークレットゾーンですね
はい
トップシークレット
特別に今日は
失礼します
先ほどと同じ作業をしたものがここにあります
あっ、あれが結晶化したものが
はい
まさにあれを例えば3日くらい置いたものがこれだと思ってください
全く一緒ですね中にガラス管が入っていて
先にゲルチューブが刺さっていて
結晶化促進剤が入っていると
全く一緒のものがここにあります
じゃあ実際に見てみましょう
こういうふうに一本のガラスの中にいっぱいあるのわかりますか？
こちらのほうが細かいですよね
細かいのいっぱい出ていますよね
こちらは割りと大きめのものがぽつぽつと出ていますよね
地上で精一杯結晶が出る条件
こちらで言うと下の方が良いですけれども
を探してこのものを宇宙に持っていく
そのための下準備をこの部屋でやっているということです
（はじめ）あっこれがゲルチューブですね
そうですね
あーいた
テンション上がりますね（笑）
そうなんですよ～（笑）
ホントその通りで、テンション上がるんです
タンパク質の結晶が
（はじめ）うわあぁぁぁ～
入っています
すぅご～い
１つのタンパク質の品質を上げるために
無数の条件で試してそれで初めて宇宙に
宇宙実験って凄く機会が貴重なので
ギリギリまで条件検討して良い結晶が出るように
地上でこういうふうにいっぱい実験をしていると
どうでしたはじめしゃちょー
いや～なんかすごい色んなことが分かったというか
なんだろう宇宙でこんな事もされているんだなっというのが
今回凄い沢山勉強になりました
本当はもうおっしゃる通りでこれだけではなくて
沢山沢山ほかにも実験しているので
本当はぜひ伝えたいところなのですけどお時間が
そうなんですよね
またぜひいらしてください
はい
今日は本当にありがとうございました
はい、ありがとうございました
はい、ということでですね
なんと10月26日に
JAXAのチャンネルで大西さんと僕でですね
宇宙実験に関する交信イベントを行うことになりました
こちらですねなんと生配信ですのでぜひ皆さん
JAXAのチャンネルの方で御覧ください
でですね大西さんに質問したいこととか
皆さん宇宙に関して知りたいこととか
沢山あると思うんですけども
ぜひこの動画のコメント欄でこういう事を聞いてみたいとか
こういう事を知りたいとかあったらぜひ
コメントで書いてみてください
ひょっとしたらライブイベント中に質問するかもしれません
今回ですね宇宙センターの普段行けないようなところまで潜入させて頂きました
本当に今日はありがとうございました。×2
とっても貴重な経験で色んなことが勉強になりました
JAXAチャンネルでのライブ配信楽しみにしていてください
ばいば～い
♪~ED~♪